ok vou aproveitar para gravar um dueto
com muito medo mas ao de salto portão e
deixou o texto com a troca de espiões
entre o tua eo ao sol o que falar andar
que sejam muito bem vindos rajoelina não
só contava com meu pai a lenda é bem
provável que eu vou fazer um vídeo se
olha só por isso ai é e tão horrível
mesmo e sensual mais um vídeo aqui
sentar nesta cadeira por que não posso
fazer coisas já se registados para quem
segue no instagram sabe que aconteceu um
pequeno acidente é porque o teu pé e eu
não gosto mais porque o corpo foi muito
grave aos 25 pontos o corte foi profundo
só não foi aqui a imagem porque não viu
tudo cota utilização porque é um
ferimento grave pois já sabe como é não
imaginou não comida né então não vamos
entrar mas passei lá no instagram que só
ficam lá porque o agricultor japonês
sobre a minha vida disse que não existe
não foi nada de moleza mas eu tenho nada
a fazer que muita coisa na colômbia é
impossível de festa de aniversário com
muitas poças participaram vieram aqui
mesmo a sério só vem acontecendo mesmo
muita coisa portanto seria um lado está
grande eo visado de tudo inclusive olha
só piora o youtube e possuem um x em
cima de mim eo mec gordo sou eu o quadro
eu tô com medo porque a pessoa que
deixou os presentes ao portão para
deixar apresentar minha porta
meu deus perigoso mesmo saber que fora
isso também tenha que muitas casas muito
importante que o bloco brics presente
oes da turbina que uma moldura é por
isso que eu gosto já votei porque o
senhor não pode ser fica fica quieta
pelo pp
eu quero discutir muito laquê neste
vídeo aqui e por falar em life roupa no
vídeo passado da minha tarefa eu pensei
em mil likes mostra ter fundamento dos
100 light houve como era minha tarântula
aflita com óbvio que eu ia comer a casca
da minha tranqüilo e basicamente o que
aconteceu
nós batemos o sangue light por isso eu
vou ter que comer é minha tarefa frita
próximo vídeo
assistam vejam por fazer lindo mas a
falha só deixei muito mais que neste
vídeo e por que não foi à festa aqui em
casa vocês podem estar comigo já dias 7
e 8 de setembro
está no porto dia 8 está em coimbra para
a sessão de autógrafos do euro
leio um livro gigante e perceber melhor
informação obra e por ser a equipe que
ficou aqui vai ter sido porto e coimbra
quando vocês por lá vamos fazer história
pressão só lavar os pés em cima do laço
pai é festa é e
[Música]
domingos lágrimas
a johnson johnson e disse lhe para
assistir relacionais usar como a linha
faz gostoso
no extenso da não é isso que o cheiro de
sangue é isso
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mas o mundo é e não é
izumi abiquim não quer agora para lá
brito disse o presidente portista deram
porque o província na festa que eu ia
ver em vídeo quando eu não posso falhar
na promessa
não vou falar porque é eu vou deixar a
surpresa do inter mais uma pro fim
porque vamos dar atenção primeiro as
pessoas torçam lojas bem que eu acho que
isso é uma pessoa que gosta de mim mas
para todo o lado mas para lá vamos ver
um saco maior estresse uma jóia
espero que seja um dia antes perto
estava nervoso não gasto dinheiro comigo
não me pronuncio não acho que eu nem sei
como é que sabe o cruzeiro
obrigada a quem o senhor gostaria mas
não certo num carro na hora que eu só
queria agradecer ou seja a pessoa que
exprime deixar só a mim e outros
milhares de pessoas todos os dias
vocês não podem dizer isso continuar
assim que um dia vai fazer milhões de
pessoas pobres e eu quero estar a ajudar
e eu também falei eu não sei se vou ter
tempo agora vestido para ler todas as
cartas mas como vocês sabem a lei sempre
portanto não se preocupem eu vou ler
tudo nosso presente é que já tem um
design aí agora por ser uma língua só
ganha desenho animado mais belo mais
bonito mas tudo muito obrigado obrigado
pelo design ou eu acredito eu fosse olha
só não só a série não gasto dinheiro
comigo aqui faz com que eu tinha que
passar dos anos que é isso que eu gosto
muito obrigado office boy na próxima
casa mas vamos lá ver como vai se
prender mais olha só para o dólar é de
mim muito obrigado maioria negra de
cheiro e esquecem da embalagem branca
porque
muita coisa em um só tema frutos aqui
mas não deixou o felicitou a eles que eu
gosto e acaba aqui
olha só clicar aqui rodrik pra sinte
estudar e cuidar
obrigado obrigado bem também eles costa
i ii ou vocês também podem obter comida
é desejo de inês costa deixou isto foi
legal ver o que o google na rua mas não
em que outro quadro muita coisa muito
louca
o ovo é muito louco ordem de outro braço
obras bem forte para brigar com as
fichas mesmo optimismo
vamos lá ver o que tem e logo a ideia
kaká dentro do mesmo saco ainda tem
outra coisa que conquistamos moldura
muito goku lei lhes dar que surgiu na
grande destino da área só para quem não
sabe o sushi bar é um dos meus fãs que
está mais rápida e fácil integração
possa muita coisa minha
vai sempre ter comida tudo lá é essa
menina é muito fofo muito fofinho agosto
no hotel e vejo sofre menores custos
iguais ao meu livro olha aí mais
presente só hoje se sabe que aqui parece
servindo ó pessoal pois foi aí é uma
almofada e essa foto foi uma foto que eu
tirei culto macho na fnac do colombo
também é não tomar chuva número um da
pena machico calheta machico ela deixa
uma presença online por aí e isto é tão
forte que eu tô muito obrigado a queimar
seus prêmios e shows incríveis e agora
então a carta do nosso amigo é isso é
muito provavelmente a uma criança que
seja stop car na pista
hua olha só a carta pegue nem tudo isso
que os fãs rotários uma galinha morta
esse é um tema cuba roja assim ó encherá
o lixo meu deve ter aqui uma sanfona
eu não vou ficar aqui não falei que tem
ótimos serpentinas de festa mas tá
pesado sem qualquer coisa no fundo quem
é duro e oi
o magic ottawa o erro só que agora estou
aqui uma ratoeira desgraça mas o bairro
quando foi a noite de sábado 17 mil
atuais
acaba atuando dentro de um fato como eu
não pensei nisso
ganhar é só para o hotel corre o tocar
que eu fui um dos cães já traz de volta
os outros fiéis mas aí como fica porque
com os filhos para que vocês tenham
gostado muito obrigada a quem por cima
aqui da minha festa e já sabem se ganhar
um integrante de exceto o estado no
porto de onde eu gostaria em coimbra
passei lá sessão de autógrafos e vamos
todos à caça do edilson não faço mais
nada porque essa brincadeira teve graça
mas ele só fica
[Aplausos]
[Música]